hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
four of our coverage at the 2017 Grand
Prix in Geneva third leg of the Grand
Prix there's four rounds total our
competitors today White's gonna be
played by Peter Sadler currently the
15th ranked player in the world
he has three draws in the first three
rounds of the Grand Prix Geneva his
opponent playing the black pieces is
Michael Adams currently the 24th ranked
player in the world he has a win in two
drawl so both of these players still in
contention with many more rounds to go
but we'll go and get into it Peter
starts out with pawn to c4 pawn e6 at
night C 3 and then after pawn to d5 pawn
d4 we get into the Queen's game decline
line so we've had a lot of Queens gambit
declined that seems to be the meta at
this tournament but we'll continue
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 Bishop e7 this
starts to get into exactly what we saw
in game 1 from a nice teary when he
started with Bishop to f4 compared to
your normal Bishop to g5 but after
Bishop to f4 Castle on the kingside pawn
to e3 and Knight to d7 so I may look
familiar this is exactly how that
started now in a shear in game 1 played
pawn to c5 kind of an unusual opening we
do at Peter Svidler
going with more the traditional route
just playing Queen to c2 Michael Adams
continues with pawn to c5 just
counter-attacking on the center of the
board pawn takes on d5 Knight recaptures
tonight recaptures here and then Bishop
here to d3 getting ready to castle on
the Kings side it's kind of blown up
right here on the Queen side so we don't
really expect him to be castling on the
Queen side of the board Queen down here
to a5 and he has a few options you could
see a pawn to h6 the bishop and of the
Queen are both attacking the square here
on 87 so it has to something Queen down
here to a5 is a check so that just kind
of forced his opponents hand if you pawn
to h6 you could see the capture here
Knight takes on c5 castle on the Kings
side this is one option he decides to go
for a little bit different route and
play Queen to a5 and then Queen up here
to c3 block
that and then clean back here to v6 and
now if the Queen wants to come to let's
say c2 again with this double-barrel
here on the h7 diagonal then all of a
sudden black has a queen in a better
position than he was before so it kind
of gains a tempo in that spot so why he
decides not to do that instead decides
to go ahead and play pawn to a3 looking
to push forward if he wants to with pawn
to b4 and then we started to see a
capture in the center of the board the
Queen on b6 also helps control the turn
of the void right here so we do see a
capture the night down here to c5 is
kind of opening up the door if Michael
Adams wants to exchange Queens off the
board he will definitely have a weakness
as far as the sinners controlled because
then if we do see you know capture you
can see the knight capture could even
see the pawn capture if he wants to have
how these uh you know pawned in the
center with no protection on either side
but either way black is not really going
to have center control why it's going to
have two central bishops so although I
think blacks probably good not to
exchange his Queens off board but this
is decided to go and get his knight
involved into the action Knight to a c5
opening up the door for his LightSquared
bishop I think you should be playing
Knight 2 or Bishop down here to g4 at
some point really wants to get this
activated in the game Bishop back here
to a c2 does not want to trade off his
LightSquared bishop and then Queen down
here to b5 stopping the castle on the
Kings side
you can't castle through a potential
checks all this is not check it is
attacking the square here on f1 so can't
castle through that [ __ ] from up here
to e5 just attacking the square here on
g7 and then pawns f6 this is kind of
tricky because yes it stops the threat
of the bishop coming here to g7 also
stops the threat of the night coming up
here to g5 which is always a you know
important square when your opponent
plays Knight to f3 which is very very
common so that's why a lot of times
you'll see pawn to h6 at some point from
black but what this does do is it opens
up the Kings side of the board from
black now if he could get this pawn off
the board bring his King over here to h8
really try to control this sim
open file with his rook on the F file
that could definitely be good but right
now all of a sudden the light square
bishop from white just kind of lights up
and says this is now more valuable piece
because you can really just hone in on
this light square diagonal right here so
that's what why it's kind of looking at
for now he's going to go ahead and
retreat his dark square bishop since it
is under attack and then Queen here to
c4 and this is kind of one of those
where if I look at it it looks as though
he played this pawn to f6 I'm not even
sure that he felt good about it he sees
that he could get in some tricky
situations from his opponent and so he
decides to go ahead and exchange
material down on board because he thinks
it could be less complicated of a
position maybe gives him a better
opportunity into the endgame and more of
a trollish place where there's less
material that he has to worry about rook
comes over here to c1 and then we do see
the exchange on board so as pieces come
off this King side weakness definitely
diminishes a little bit from black which
is kind of what Michael Adams was going
for pawn to e5 Knight up here to b5
starting a pretty strong attack it is
interesting if you look from blacks
point of view he's yet to get his
LightSquared Bishop involved into the
game I think that is kind of a weakness
that he has in his preparation for this
opening wide on the other hand doing a
job controlling a lot of the board
dislikes career bishops putting a lot of
pressure on the King side aboard this
dark square Bishop is controlling this
entire diagonal right here and also the
rook on a eight really can't get
activated right now we would like to
kind of double these up bring his work
over here to c8
for these other work over here to e8
potentially d8 if you want to start
pushing up his pawn a little bit he's
not really doing that because his
LightSquared bishop is blocked
he first brings his a work over here to
d8 to one of those that we talked about
Knight up here to c7 attacking the rook
here on a 8 this Knight is protected by
the bishop as we talked about on g3 rook
down here a 7 not really where you want
your rook to be just protecting this
lonely pawn knowing that it can't come
here to a6 as well because the knight
would capture it we're over here to d1
now both the night and the
rook are both attacking this pawn right
here so it gets a little tricky because
how do you really stop this you could
bring your Bishop down here to e6 but
then just pawn up here to b4 you could
see an exchange on board nice not really
going you know to move because then just
the bishops going to fall so you could
see the bishop come down here to g4
attacking the rook
but then pawn up here to f3 and it just
gets tricky depending on where you know
black wants to go you know he brings his
knight here because if it were to take
you to bring his Bishop down here and
take but all now it gets kind of
confusing as far as how he stops this he
decides to go for a interesting line i
think and that is king to f7 this has
another weakness is this square here on
h7 is no longer protected so white has a
few options he can start to attack this
square in the center of the board which
taking your opponent's pawns from the
center so you control more that Center I
think it's always good plan and then
later on he can start to chip away on
the pawn structure over here on the
Kings side the boards that's what he
starts with Knight takes on d5 pawn here
to be 5 and then castle on the Kings
side does have some King side safety now
and now he could just continue his game
plan even if he wants to trade down
after the bishop takes on 87 he's going
to have a better end game because he has
more material now Michael Adams decides
to play Bishop back here to f8 not a
huge fan of this move I recognize he
doesn't want to get rid of his Bishop
pair and so he decides you know this
nice attacking me right here so I don't
have a lot of good options if it brings
you here to d6 his opponent could just
play Knight to b6 this gets into a lot
of trouble this is a discovered attack
with the rook on the bishop here also
the bishop could take it and I think
this is completely fine for white to
kind of exchange down material he's also
going to be taking that pawn up here on
h7 so this is kind of tough for black
but if he just brings it back to f8 he
has both of his bishops on the
eighth-ranked that's not really where
you want that to be so yes although he
may lose his bishop pair I think in some
situations it's okay to just trade off
the site for Bishop you don't want to
have just a bishop that's no longer in
the game but that's what it does Bishop
here to f8
then the bishop takes on 87 pawn down
here to a g5 trying to push a little bit
but not doing too much pawn to h4 Bishop
down e 6 finally after 25 moves in the
game we see the light square Bishop
getting involved into the game I think
is a little bit too late but that's ok
please pawn to e4 could have tried
something else it was somewhat difficult
to find and so I think he for getting a
nice little outpost for the night here
on d5 is completely fine
there was a tricky combination that kind
of the commentators were looking at
we're looking at through all the lines
that Y could play and that's Bishop to
g8 and after the King takes we see
Knight takes on f6 check and there is
also the discovered attack you can see
up here on d8 so once the King comes
down work up here to d8 capture maybe
Bishop to e7 attacking both the pieces
Bishop appeared e6 if the rook takes or
the bishop takes the rook Bishop here to
c5 oh just some exchanges on board which
i think is good for white so we could
have played a line that I think was a
little bit more aggressive on trading
down material he is up three pawns in
material so if you were to do this I
think it would be fantastic
but at the end of the day he decides to
go and play pawn to e4 and then black
decides to go ahead and just start
exchanging which is you know if you
would have known that you would exchange
you may not have thought as long as you
did about the pawn to e4 but Bishop
takes on h4 Bishop takes on d5 start in
the exchange on board the rooks exchange
now there is a passed pawn on the D fall
for white so black has to worry about
that night over here to a4 attacking the
pawn on a b2 and then rook to c1 and I
kind of thought that you know Knight
comes here to a4 starting to attack the
pawn on b2 I think you can take this
right here but you know after you see
your opponent play this attack from your
pawn you play real cover here to c1
knowing that you can bring it into the
attack it almost looks like a trap from
blacks point of view like maybe I
calculated incorrectly it doesn't really
look as good anymore to take this pawn
because you have the advantage and you
did not seem to care about it at all
so instead place rook to the e7 which
does make some sense although it's
probably not the sharpest line for black
just taking the pawn I see
gives a little bit better then work up
here to see six nice little outpost
although you usually don't see outpost
from a rook that's kind of what he has
right here and why could just keep all
his material into the board off of the
dark squares the dark square bishop the
black has can't really do a lot if
pieces aren't on the dark squares that's
what Peter Spindler is thinking about
right now we do see the rook take and
that's fine work over here on f6 check
forcing the King to move and then Bishop
back here to see - now the knight takes
on a b2 finally a rook to g6 check King
over here to f7 and will you see a few
more checks on board and then a roof
over here to b6 so not only attacking
the pawn if the rook moves but then also
allowing himself to come up to the
seventh rank always a very powerful rank
on the board for the rooks to come to
check and then he can kind of mover his
bishops around as well to have a very
strong attack on his opponent getting
into the endgame Michael Adams plays
Bishop to c5 getting involved into the
game but almost seems like he's just not
exactly sure where he should be going
with his arcs relationship definitely
way too late to try to get involved too
much but it brings the attack down all
this is going to do is allow white to do
what he wanted to do in the first place
bring his rook to b7 King to f8 so now
he's kind of stopped
this has ported some of what blacks
would like to do you know it could have
tried to be a little bit more aggressive
you didn't have tons of squares could
have come here to h6 because both f6 and
g6 are blocked off because of the
bishops but now all of a sudden the King
can only move on this eighth-ranked
right here so now that white has him
kind of trapped here now I can start to
maneuver his bishops around if he wants
to push forward with his pawns he can do
that as well if he needed to activate
his King he can do that start to build
up an attack on the Kings side and then
is once the King can't move then you
could just have the Rick come up here to
b8 for a checkmate Bishop here to g6
starting the attack Bishop here to d4
not really sure this is doing too much
as well Bishop e7 check King to g8 and
then kind of the final nail in the
coffin
to f6 and at this point Michael items
decides to go ahead and resign and we
see that these bishops are blocking off
all of these squares that the king would
like to go to can't go to any of those
he is threatening mate in one
rook here to BH would be made so the
only way to really stop this would be
Bishop to f6 taking but then from here
we just see Bishop to f7 King to h8 and
then the bishop is going to take the
rook here on a d5 these pawns are going
to fall and then a rook and Bishop with
some pawn in game is just going to be
too much for black in this particular
point black decides to go ahead and
resign so Peters feel a great game from
him you know one of the top players in
the world so good to see him coming to
this tournament prepared had a good
series so far so we'll expect to see
more from him I thank you guys for
watching round 4 of the Grand Prix in
Geneva and we will see you tomorrow for
round number 5